oh that's a strange one yeah we started
this game and he played b3 offering a
draw i don't want to draw I i mean i
sent an aboard request which she
declined and i don't get why you would
offer a draw them don't know well ok
let's see what will get you not taking a
draw anyway i usually beat this guy so
let's see what we can do here it's a
pretty strange position out of one be
three but ok it looks more like a rillo
pass here willow pass delayed exchange
or something 194 now let's see this is a
very equal ish position very difficult
to get something serious going down why
does some what is very solid only plenty
really has something with f4 but it's
not fair not easy to get in c3 is just
making ass bishop bad piece at the
moment but d fork might be an idea
yeah this guy is playing 1b3 in every
game really absolutely every game never
everything never anything else which
seems kind of yeah I don't know really
every game every game sounds sounds like
some punishment so if i take it what is
he going to do I don't okay let's just
take first and think about this later or
that one okay yeah really the same move
every game and end of all moves won't be
three this is really sounds like some
kind of jail sentence or so like he
committed a crime or something like that
playing one be three for the rest of
your life guilty as charged okay d for
its ambitious opening up the position
against with with a night against a
bishop
hmm so how am I going to play may we
take them stinking Queen before as an
idea but she may be really has 250 but
sees six mmm interesting yeah let's
let's do that ideas be five and a four
trying to play on the queenside which is
mostly ignored let's let's do that then
if you move the knight to e5 I have
Bishop b3
hmm yeah well can you is there he cannot
not take I mean he has to take it so I'm
undermining the night position and he
doesn't have a great square forager if
he goes to e5 or so I checked b3 and if
he goes to D to agra take d4 was checked
so it looks a bit awkward already but
that was kind of I mean I don't know
playing d 4 against a well centralized
position with the bishop only six
against the somewhat shaky night seemed
a bit strange it shouldn't lead to
direct trouble but the way he played it
it was direct trouble ok so what do I do
now Addison number of options but I
think starting with that cannot be
cannot be wrong there are some some
technical ideas here also sometimes
okay she really have something else then
now maybe Queen d3 may be thinking
Quincy oneness looks kind of forced but
he's not playing that yet okay it's
going there
hmm interesting yeah one day ever have
something really brutal like f5 but it
might might blow up in my face I can
just take b5 that's it's not not bad
really f5 is a bit tempting though
especially considering that here is no
time ok let's let's do this might might
be bad but it will definitely cause some
lots of practical troubles ok so i take
before now rook takes this a check on c5
i can also check d5 because the rook on
f4 hangs Bishop takes d5 is a good move
here right I think that's a good move he
takes Queen f4 I'm covering b3 and I'm
threatening to move the bishop back yeah
five it was tricky it was a tricky move
I don't know if it was really
objectively great but considering the
time situation it was very difficult for
what
now sort of moose reading all kinds of
things Bishop before and what not now I
was letting the clock went down or what
okay so Bishop afire maybe
white forfeits hand time yeah that draw
off one move one was kind of strange I
don't mind if they just request in a
board sometimes you have the button
pressed and something happens and
whatever but just to draw well I don't
give away points against someone who are
usually beat okay so this was kind of
normal here it looks really not like a
Spanish exchange it's just that he did
happen truck wouldn't be three I think
this is a very equal ish position check
c3 is not a move I like very much for
white but it is ok he can always if
everything else fails you can always
take here and play d4 for total equality
it's um yeah it's it's a very boring
line yeah put those dark squares no he
went with this okay takes Bishop takes
that I found already a bit surprising
because this disc and if anybody is
better here it's black here my
membership is when tankard this is a
little bit weak there on the queenside
and I know it's I cannot do very much
I'm comfortable but I cannot do very
much in terms of going forward but after
d4 I can and I don't don't like that for
white at all now here it gets it gets
tricky to play it's probably not this
something that I computer will probably
still play all right because it won't
run into any of the technical problems
but for you minutes it's very easy I
know after be five white is just losing
right yeah the comp is just living a
Lhasa minus 1.5 or so yeah that's it's
really the way to play and f5 is the
best move okay or one of the best moves
Queen B 5 here okay so I did not I did
not make a mistake with this f5 move it
was a bit of a gambling move because I
couldn't really figure out if there is
something wrong with it and I had
alternatives of course solid ones like
Queen B five but this sum is very
difficult to meet at
Bishop g5 he was really completely lost
it was a little bit on playing on his
time situation there five move well I
didn't think it was really bad but it's
something that not not to be taken
lightly this kind of move which lets all
kinds of things hang like a sig sets on
okay well thanks for watching